[Music]
so we have been talking about nuclear
weapons all day nuclear weapons are
quite difficult sometimes and we have
been talking about the Harz and the
technical side in some ways we haven't
really talked about what they do to
people directly and the humanitarian
impact of nuclear weapons and because in
some conversations around the world we
sort of switched the focus of nuclear
weapons away from security away from
deterrence into the direct impact that
they have on people we put the human
first because of that most of the
world's governments are now started
negotiations a start and a march and
they did it because they're going to
make nuclear weapons illegal and at the
center of that our people and it's to
prevent ever seeing another mushroom
cloud it's to prevent ever having
another person that is burned or blown
up whose family is scarred for
generations by nuclear weapons
it's a ban then not everybody is on
board with the band and that's okay not
everybody has to agree with everything
right but most of the countries in the
world thinks nuclear weapons are
unnecessary for security that they
should be illegal just like other
weapons of mass destruction biological
weapons chemical weapons they're illegal
comprehensively and thoroughly they're
still out there they're not all gone but
their ear is only made up took a moral
stance and put that moral stance into
law and that's amazing and that is
happening now and it's why even after a
day of really kind of I get a little
overwhelmed thinking about nuclear
weapons I got inspired in the climate
connect making the connections between
climate and nuclear weapons workshop I
was in over lunch I kind of got lifted
up again but it can be really hard
but I want to share with you an
enthusiasm for making any inhumane
indiscriminate weapon that is by design
set up to violate international
humanitarian law by design make that
illegal because it's going to happen but
the nuclear-armed countries not
necessarily going to join on and the
United States is not very good at
signing up to new treaties especially
new treaties that make weapons illegal
so we have to think about what we can do
about that
alright so that's what I want to talk to
you about things we can do because I
like to do stuff doing stuff makes
change happen I'm going to come after
there's a couple of different ways we
can do things one thing is divestment
and I write this report every year I
have some copies not a lot of copies but
please you take them home so I don't
have to I write this report every year
just updates called don't bank on the
bomb and what it does it looks at the 27
companies that are most heavily involved
in the production of nuclear weapons
gives information about their contracts
how much money they're making to make
these horrible weapons and in this
handy-dandy table says hard to do this
one hand so who's investing in those
those companies now this is where you
can do something you can personally take
action on the issue of nuclear weapons
because you probably eliminate let me
ask this question is there anybody here
who does not have a bank account okay
everybody got a bank down this room
alright all of you then have something
you can do and you can contact your bank
and say hey are you investing in nuclear
weapon producers and if you are please
stop and if you're not do you have a
policy that says that you're not but
it's a really easy thing you can do I
use a banking all the time because I'm
like that on the phone and I have tried
and sent messages to my bank through my
phone just to say hey are you is
connected to nuclear weapon pretty
so for those of you who believe in a
banking and to trust the unsecured MIT
Network you can you can do that
otherwise you can wait to get home or
you can walk into your local bank branch
ask the manager hey does this bank
invest in nuclear weapon producers
managers not going to know the answer to
that question the manager is however
going to know he potentially has a
public relations nightmare on their
hands because nobody wants to be
associated with the production of
weapons designed to violate the
fundamental principles of international
humanitarian law something you can
everybody can do this and it's pretty
straightforward and there's a lot of
examples on our website of letters you
can send if you don't want to just send
them a quickie quickie message we also
found some great success with this and a
couple of people saw an article and
newspaper in Sweden and started a little
Facebook like they started asking
questions on Facebook of their bank that
bank now has a pretty good policy on
doesn't invest in any nuclear weapon
producers this Fed bank because they've
picked out because the public relations
relations nightmare so that's something
if you probably have a lot of you have
pension funds you can ask the same
questions of your pension funds and I
hope you have insurance because
insurance is important we can ask the
same questions for your insurance agents
are you sure insurance companies all of
these are potential investors in the
nuclear weapon production complex and
you can find out you know if they are
investing using our report or you can
just ask them directly so that's quite
quite cool and they'll answer you which
is nice it's nice to see and nice to see
something that's that's very winnable in
this but when you personally do now if
you want to work together with other
people because that's always very good
there's ways to take this issue around
divestment and take it to the city level
here in Cambridge there was a great
example of this as announced last year
and mayor Simmons referred to it this
morning there is a resolution passed in
the City Council to make sure that the
that the city pension council pension
fund is not invested in nuclear weapon
producers since that happened other
cities are looking as you
same thing and Takoma Park Maryland
which is you know it's right next to DC
Takoma Park they have this nuclear
weapon-free zone status a lot of cities
do it was mentioned before congresswoman
barbara Lee mentioned she was part of
the same freeze campaign that set up
nuclear weapon-free zones all over the
country kkoma parks nuclear weapon-free
zone city they decided to move their
bank so they're moving their a huge
amount of money in their bank and
they're moving their bank they're
changing banks to a bank that has no
relationship with a nuclear weapons
industry because if they stick up stick
with the bank that they have which is
SunTrust financial just you know for
your info they're worried that they'll
you know be violating their own
principles around this nuclear
weapon-free zone status it's super cool
and it happened because a couple of
people got together they brought it to
the City Council they pushed for it and
they said this is this we need to stick
with our policies and that's something
you know folks here can do as well or if
you're in Cambridge I guess it's getting
in touch with people who are in other
cities getting them on board with it
this can be taken to the state level I
heard this afternoon about legislation
pending here in Massachusetts about
divesting from fossil fuels divesting
from fossil fuels is a win for us it's a
win for all of us when our when our
colleague colleagues have success we
have success and supporting that kind of
legislation is something that I think we
should all get on board with and it's a
way to elevate the issue and to elevate
the tool of moving money as a tool of
power it's a way to empower us and to
put it in things that we need and there
are examples of entire countries that
have national laws saying they will not
invest in nuclear weapon producers like
New Zealand or war materials at all like
Switzerland or Liechtenstein they're not
the best
of law ever written but there on the
books and the banks in the and the and
companies operating in those countries
have to abide by them it's just good to
know that there's that this is possible
because it is possible and it should
give us a sense of hope and with that I
want to end on a couple of couple of
small things one is I get hope when I'm
surrounded by people who are
enthusiastic and excited and share my
passions and I know the women's march to
ban the bomb that's going to take place
on the 17th of June in New York it's
going to be full of that it's a it's
amazing to see women organizing
differently and I've seen that this year
and I'm a longtime will members
and will be a will simmer for as long as
I can well I have lifetime membership so
you know as long as I live and it's
great to see we'll really taking the
lead and still in a public mobilization
and something that's moving thousands of
people have expressed interest and I
hope you come and join us in New York
and the last thing I want to say is my
thanks because future of life mit the
amazed Massachusetts Peace Action the
amazing organizers that put together
this conference that brought people here
together that gave us a space to speak
with one letter connect with one another
I really want to thank you I don't want
to say next year in the conference
program can you give us a little bit
more time to talk to each other so that
we can keep working together and I with
that I'll end and I want to thank you
all please take my papers so that I
don't take them home and thank you again
[Applause]
[Music]